now the question is what happens like we
got this right it's not wrong but
they're just gaping holes in your
solution so to help you try and work out
what's happening I want you to remember
them like I showed you this one if you
are trying to find the angle between two
lines right we are we developed out of
the expansion 14 a minus B we do not
know what's here on the is a on one line
okay now when we developed it on that
day we notice this is cool it saves you
a lot of work but there's a kind of
problem with it there's a place at which
this breaks down it doesn't always work
does it what's the value that makes this
break down if that angle is by cheating
that means that the angle between the
two lines is like a perpendicular pair
of lines right which means that this guy
here is and you're kind of stuff because
you denominator becomes zero and that's
a bit of a problem
okay Tan has this issue because it's got
asymptotes at 90 and 270 and 5 or
whatever wound up in ok so 450 so this
is problem Alice do you see why it lands
not a problem here
what come on which solution do we get we
got 90 that was cool good
the solution we were missing is 180 it
just sort of disappeared off the face of
the earth why did 180 disappear
it's on viewer that's true but I
actually could move this round and it
could happen elsewhere like for example
I just take this whole thing and weave
it up like five units both graphs they
weren't intersected zebra or anymore but
I still won't get the solution there's
another problem with 180 degrees but if
x equals money even if you put it into
10x of the tooth so my premise for this
whole set up the soon as I started doing
this I was assuming everything was in
terms of tan right how many tens do you
see in the original equation not we
introduced them right and the second you
introduced them you sort of open
yourself up to this problem because of
course if I think an X on two then you
stick 180 degrees in there and lo and
behold you have 1090 which has
established is a big problem so the T
results they are wonderful they're
incredibly useful they open up I mean
that question we did what was it five
side x minus current a back thing right
there's really not other nice way to
deal with it you'll find there are but
they're not nice but it has this problem
right so you actually have to overcome
it by saying whatever solutions you get
at the end you have to test you have to
say wait you having your nay degrees a
solution because if it is this will not
find it so how do we test if hundred any
breeze is actually a solution
you do exactly what we did before with
the solution you did fine right we
expect the naive solution so we kept it
for now please put this underneath your
working wherever you set active learning
now you need to test X equals 108 you
don't usually have to do this you have
to do this with any object of those
solutions requests as you have done
before you had to do it because you
introduced the method that if you like
has a blind spot right this time
this method tears off it can't see 180
degrees right it's a little bit like
someone who's colorblind is you give
them stuff agree they can't tell the
difference this guy can't recognize open
a business solution so you are an
obligation to test okay let's do it left
hand side includes what some money I
have a value now I'm going to test the
right hand side cars won eight years
that's zero left hand side does equal to
right hand side are hot even though T
results couldn't find the solution just
manually testing it which is a bit
sorely tested luck is really on the
heart is it like it's really simple work
your calculator can do it too since left
hand side and right hand side are equal
X hundred need is a solution when you
receive a question in anything that
includes T results that involves solving
an equation or certainly if we work at
three or four marks the third or the
fourth mark is for this person when you
end up with the solution or not I have
to go back to the one that we tried this
morning how would we say five sine X
minus cos x 18 to write again if I go
back to that I bought two solutions out
but 180 could be a solution so I'm going
to test
five times
Simon ate with that that zero cause 180
that is we just said it negative 1 minus
negative 1 so that's one which is not
the right hand side so therefore in this
case X equals 180 is not solution which
is really if I straight in the graph
you know what we saw all the questions
that you're good so x equals 180 is not
a solution every time you see results
for this kind of problem for solving an
equation you must test you must have
because apparently platform
so therefore the hanging I like to call
this in the trouble with T results
they're cool
it really aren't quite ingenious but
they have this problem this white spot
its Achilles heel this is what you need
to watch